on Sunday April 12th President Trump
retweeted a call to fire dr. Anthony
Fauci dr. Falchi is the longtime
director of the National Institute of
Allergy and Infectious Diseases
and a key player in the Trump
administration's handling of the novel
coronavirus pandemic the tweet in
question referred to an interview foul
she did with CNN where he implied that
if the Trump administration had acted
sooner more lives would have been saved
you could logically say that if you had
a process that was ongoing and you
started mitigation earlier you could
have saved lives obviously no one is
gonna deny that
despite amplifying a call to fire him
which caused the hashtag fire foul
cheats a trend on Twitter Trump has
praised foul Qi on several occasions we
have whether it's doctor foul Qi we have
the best people on earth we have the
most talented people
doctor doctor pouchy is great no he's a
good man I like dr. Fauci a lot just so
you understand
he was a great basketball player did
anybody know a couple of years ago four
years ago they had never changes the
attitude never changes I have great
respect for this group in fact I told
Tony for ouchy I said why don't you move
to New York run against AOC you will win
easily and at an April 13th press
briefing Trump was asked why he
retweeted a call to fire Falchi today I
walk in I hear I'm gonna fire him I'm
not firing I think he's a wonderful
recently sent fire
i retweeted somebody I don't know they
said fire doesn't matter I was
immediately called upon that and I said
no I like them
I think he's terrific